all didn't rescue this out okay okay I
can't do the sound
what is it CRX ound does it I'm Chris
Pratt and I'm Bryce Dallas
I was sent in some dinosaur videos and
we are going to rate them that's good
this is sent in by / Morton
[Music]
full commitment that's that's really
admirable
listen I'm terrified the goal is to
scare us with Dinosaurs you've done it I
think the sunglasses and babushka yeah
yeah it's some sort of Russian hat yeah
off camera the sound itself sounded like
maybe you were yeah is there any any
critiques any feedback yes don't ever do
that again all right Graham here we go
yeah terrible already wrapped er like
reflexes that this buck was amazing the
sound was amazing
it looks like your breads were really
enjoying it I know we were really
enjoying it
clear clear front-runner right there
that's a ten out of ten yeah great nice
job this is sent in by comb
[Music]
[Laughter]
dangerous situation that looks like it's
so much fun though Wow he's like Warren
Miller quality that was really good
reaction 10 out of 10 that's commitment
commitment to me goes a long way
you know you get to the top of the
mountain in the t-rex suit you shot the
video any advice keep it up you're going
places okay oh boy that that looks like
this is senton by Samantha
he said he sounds like t-rex from
Jurassic Park okay the t-rex impression
is basic play by my side yeah baby arms
like that's kind of what you see t-rex
is doing mr. I just know I'll do the
other direction is that okay right I
can't do the sound
what is it see Rex sound does it
[Laughter]
that's right
Samantha he's right he does sound like
t-rex from Jurassic Park he's blowing
his nose I think wow I'm impressed yeah
any advice I'd say don't do that too
much and will damage your sinuses thank
you lad Bible for sending in your
dinosaur videos it's been a lot of fun
and dinosaurs rule